[Music]
Pacific Rim was a movie made for the
simple fact that people wanted to see
giant monsters fight giant robots deeper
than we all want to see that and we want
to feel the terror of seeing monsters
tearing away our fabric of reality but
we also want to have the means to fight
them back and if superpowers are off our
limits then giant robots it is the
jaegers in the Pacific Rim were designed
as mecca's piloted by two people
connected mentally in order to move very
agile they were made to counter the
guide use and in this video we shall
showcase the 10 biggest hagas so here it
goes
number 10 striker Eureka era number 10
spot come strike a Eureka which is an
Australian mark 5 Jaeger designed to
defend the coastline of Australia from
the kaiju it was the first and the only
mark 5 Jaeger and service as of the
first events of Pacific Rim 1 and also
the last Jaeger to be constructed in the
events of 2025 before its destruction
striker Eureka was launched in 2019 and
it earned 11 kills while most of the
kills were solo the strongest and the
fastest of the jaegers striker Eureka's
fighting style is akin to that of a
dirty boxer or brutal brawler strikers 6
barrel wmb - in 290 anti kg missile
chest launcher it's equipped with 18
individual case tunnel warheads that
kill kaiju with a single direct hit it
also has heat-resistant brass knuckles
cos around the joints of each finger
extension adding greatly to the impact
potential of each punch striker Eureka
stands 250 feet tall or seventy six
point two meters and weigh in at 18 to
50 tons number 9 Sabre Athena the
sleekest and the most elegant yaga ever
created Sabre Athena is the fastest in
the fleet
wielding twin blades in hyper acrobatic
combat Sabre Athena was launched on the
20th of December twenty thirty three and
was named after the Greek goddess of
wisdom and military victory she is a
mark seven Jaeger and was stationed
alongside valor Omega and garden Bravo
as reinforcement for gypsy Avenger
during the parade she was
design as a new approach to combating
kaiju due to the increase in size and
strength rendering the strategy of
overpowering them obsolete instead of
focusing on brute strength and armored
zebra thena relied on its high agility
dealing the single killing blow to an
exhausted enemy with its ionic twin
blades among its other weapons re n 16
particle charger a magnetically
accelerated plasma cannon that pops out
of the jaegers left forearm she s 252
feet tall or seventy six point eight
meters and weigh 1638 tons number eight
Titan Redeemer on this rank we have the
Titan Redeemer which is a mark 6 jäger
unmatched in brute force and reliability
under the harshest conditions Titan
Redeemer served as the flagship of the
Lima Panama and Vladivostok shadow drums
until its destruction in 2035 during the
rope kaiju Yeager hybrid attack on the
shatterdome tiger Redeemer is deployed
fight back against the invading force
and during the battle title Redeemers
knee and shin are destroyed by a group
of swarm missiles with its remaining
strength and raises its right arm and
the cavity it's one of the drones with
its cannon title Redeemer as a Marxist
Jager design around its primary weapon
the m-19 Morningstar the m-19 monster
creates a seismic effect and its
secondary weapons include are mounted
cannons and the EMP miss grenade which
can disrupt electrical signals Titan is
capable of exerting 60,000 pounds of
force per punch and the m-19 morris that
can kill a category two kaiju with one
single hip and a titans armor plates
were crafted using metal from the sheer
no alpha he is 253 feet tall or 77.1
meters and weigh 2007 and 83 tonnes
number 7 Romeo blue during the early
years of the kaiju war
Romeo blue becomes the second year to be
deployed in combat when the kaiju heart
ship makes landfall after dark in an
undisclosed City Romeo blue is
ultimately able to overpower hardship
utilizing a chunk of the belt wave Ridge
as a melee weapon and consequently
earning his first guys you kill it is
the second mark one launched in the
United States after brawler UConn during
the year 2020 Romeo blue is deployed to
prevent the category 3 kaiju knife head
crossing the 10 mile point in Anchorage
when the kaiju evades detection [ __ ]
danger is deployed from the Anchorage
shadow dome to defend the Miracle Mile
Romeo Blue is equipped with very
powerful piston fists as primary melee
weapon and a G au 24 Gatling gun as
range once he also possesses a unique
experimental plasma cannon this Jaeger
is 255 feet tall or seventy seven point
seven meters and weighs 7775 tons
although his weight is greatly debated
and might have been lesser than 2000
number 6 November Ajax next comes to
November Ajax which is a mark 6 Jaeger
it was tasked with patrolling Santa
Monica and intercepting rogue Yeager's
November Ajax was the first Jaeger to
utilize the T 14 Jaeger platform this
base frame was supplied to find other
law enforcement years of similar
specification the T 14 was
conceptualized to decrease cars while
allowing for extensive modularity for
future combat spec upgrades November
Ajax is a broad-shouldered Jaeger who
the blue color scheme that in - for
Manor invokes both image of local
authorities and a militarized Pan
Pacific Defense Corps and stands at a
height of two hundred fifty nine feet of
79 meters and weigh 2,000 55 tons
November Ajax operates like an
omniscient police force on the lookout
for rope Yeager's built by civilians
stealing our purchasing Jaeger parts
from the black market and that is where
the fateful meeting with the little
scrapper took place number 5 [ __ ]
danger from the first movie [ __ ] danger
is a mark 3 American Jaeger and was one
of the oldest Jaeger still in active
combat for the first kaiju war after
share no alpha until its destruction in
2025 it was decommissioned in 2020
following its fight with a kaiju knife
head for which it won but with heavy
damages but was later recommission and
fought the category four and five kaijus
at a breach and eventually descended
into the anti verse and blew up the
kaiju facility [ __ ] dangers appearance
faded blue paint job and romanticized
echo invokes the visual design of a
fighter aircraft the Jaeger is powered
by a nuclear turbine and the turbine can
also be utilized to fire a directed heat
weapon powerful enough to puncture
kaijus it possesses
plasma caster a particle dispersive
cannon that fires plasma via a charge
carrier rail and also chainsaws that can
be used as solid blades or whips the
Jaeger stands 260 feet tall or seventy
nine point two meters and weigh 1980
tons number four gypsy Avenger gypsy
Avenger honors the heroic legacy of her
namesake as a flagship leader of the
mark six fleet more than just a Yaga she
is the symbol of hope for millions gypsy
Avenger was launched in January 12 20 30
40 structured and militarized Pan
Pacific Defense Corps prior to the
re-emergence of the kaijus in 2035 gypsy
Avenger was stationed in the Mauryan
shadow drone it had to bounce prior to
the fight against the kaiju in Tokyo and
both were against Obsidian fury [ __ ]
Avenger was built in honor of [ __ ]
danger and designed using its design
template [ __ ] Avengers arsenal include
the plasma caster the chainsaw and elbow
rocket which are identical and upgraded
weapon sets of [ __ ] danger
it was later retrofitted with obsidians
Fury's plasma chainsaws following the
Hybris destruction another additional
weapon original to the design is the
gravity sling which can disturb the
gravitational force around any object of
Avenger is 268 feet tall or 80 1.7
meters and weighs 2004 tons number three
obsidian fury next on the list at a
third rank is obsidian fury which is a
highly advanced and sentient mark 7
Jaeger the fact that it was sentient is
because it was fused with a hive mind of
the precursors which transformed it into
a hybrid obsidian fury is one of the
several Jaeger drones with technology
pioneered by shower industries and
designed by precursor control new like
the other drones it was designed without
a control board obsidian fury can
release a concentrated blast of energy
from a particle charger and particle
guns obsidian fury has two plasma chain
saws which generate immense amounts of
heat that they can slice through any
Kaiser armor with little effort
obsidian fury has shielding as its
exoskeleton meaning that she can't be
harmed by conventional kaiju or military
weapons
it was additionally armed with weaponry
such as the AKM salvo launches this
Jaeger
278 feet or eighty four point seven
meters and weigh close to two thousand
one hundred tons
number two coyote tango this is the
second mark one Jaeger from Japan
launched in December 30th 2015 it was
one of the oldest Yeager's and active
service before its destruction during
the kaiju War Korea tango sustains major
damages from bowels again kaiju attack
add an undetermined point of the war
kyuri tango is destroyed during battle
and as pilots are killed Korea tango is
designed to resemble naval warships and
Cobra attack helicopters in both color
scheme and appearance theory tangos
light armor allows you to perform
various deadly maneuvers and has great
speed to evade kaiju attacks it is also
armed with twin long-range ballistic
water cannons to damage guide you from
afar
hurry tango is also tight with channel
alpha for the tallest height of a Jaeger
it is do er an 80 feet tall or eighty
five point three meters and weigh two
thousand three hundred and twelve tons
number one chair no alpha one of the
toughest heaviest and strongest Yeager's
in the kaiju war channel alpha is a Mach
1 Jaeger while the kaijus knew him as a
devastating war machine Chiana alpha is
one of the last remaining Jaeger's in
the Chi Chi war until his destruction in
2025 Shanno is designed to come face to
face with his close combat skills that
can easily [ __ ] guide you channel is
one of the heaviest oldest and best
armored Yeager's as well as one of the
slowest it ties with Korea tango for the
tallest height of a Mach 1 Jaeger
visually channel alpha was designed and
pattern to resemble Russian military
painting schemes and in particular
Russian tanks
Shanno alphas heavily armoured arms are
equipped with a weapon codenamed
roll of nickels this Jaeger is the
biggest standing at or an 80 feet tall
or eighty five point three meters and
weighs two thousand four and twelve tons
and with this we come to the end of the
list of the jaegers be sure to check out
the kaiju video as well and also do like
share and subscribe for more related
content